Hey guys! Before we get started with the game I wanted to let you know that CLOAK has new shir-
*camera jumps off table* AHH
Cloak has new shirts for pride month!
They're great! We also have...
* Mark Noises* Hoodies!
Hats and Shorts!
And best of all half of all proceeds are going towards the Trevor Project!
So go to cloakbrand.com or click in the link in the description below and find some for yourself.
Thanks so much and back to the game!
Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Five Nights at Freddy's VR.
I am... just about done with your bullshit buddy.
I like that the music cut off there because I wanted to reiterate my point with some definite severity.
But, we need to go into the- KACHUNK!
Wishy-washy nightmare world.
Where you've got.. a little more substantiationty, huh, buddy?
Huh, dont'cha?
Now, I know I have not been the best about getting all the tapes and the yadda yadda and the what-that.
And I still don't know what this button do,
*presses button*
Nor do I *bump* think I wanna know what that button do.
But I don't know what that button do.
Can that music not be so ear-scratchingly horrifying?
So what I'm gonna do is I'm not go to the basic Five Nights at Freddy's levels.
Mostly just because...
I really wanna see...
A-And I feel like I've earned the ability to pick and choose which one I go to next,
I wanna see how THESE
change because Bonnie in this picture really grabbed my attention,
And I don't know how it's gonna be trying to change out a horrifying nightmare version of... Bonnie?
Or why this is just some bizarre nightmare world anyway, but...
HERE WE GOOOO!!!
*dramatic stinger*
WOAH!
fucking
GOD DAMMIT!
[creepy chaotic music playing]
okay...
great!
What the hell?
Wait, so what's different about it then, besides the really messed up music?
You sittin' on... Okay so it's the same coin I got before-
*poof*
Doesn't even exist anymore I guess
Okay, left eye! Your left eye!
Don't mess with me buddy!
Because, I ain't about this bullshit!
You gotta, weh-!
You got a weiiiird face.
And I don't like it, oh my God.
*grunt*
Okay, everything's fine.
Thank you.
You got it!
Sounds good to me buddy, I like it!
Can I have this please? Can I has this?
Greaaaat.
Alright. You're not gonna mess with me this time,
'Cause I know...
What you do...
When I do this!
ih !
yeeeahhhhh
Alright!
O K A Y !
[guitar tuning, one note is off-key]
Right...
I know which one it was.
Uh huh.
Alright...
Just that easy, huh?
Not much different going on here..
All feels the same, actually!
Oh, okay!
What- wait is that it?
wait what the fuck?
[kids cheering]
Wait..
"Meat Bites.. Extra Large!"
Absolutely incredible, I do agree, but hang on, I'm very confused.
Maybe I had a complete  misunderstanding what this was all gonna entail.
Because, what the hell?
That was exactly the same.
That was the same thing except it's all freaky and weird!
But why is it all freaky and weird?
Is there something else I'm not understanding about all this?
WHOA! fuck-
GOD DAMN FUCKING-
WHAT THE FUCK IS THAT!
OH MY
GOD!
You just moved!
You just moved, didn't you?
AAAUUGH!
Ohh, I see you.
Oh, I see you. Okay, alright then.
Refuse bin it is!
Gimme that!
Gimme some-a-this!
♪ I'll take that no proooblem. ♪
Uh huh, uh huh..
[LOUD NOISE]
AYE!
Fucking, I... *grumbles*
I fucking swear to God, I fucking...
Yeah yeah I know, I remember.
ugh...
Can I have this?
Why can I not have this?
There we go.
Okay just...
Just like that!
Okay, and...
Badoinkus, youuu're fine.
Oh wait- wuhwuhwhawha?
Wha-wait!
Wha-wait.. wait what the fuck?
Okay so anyWAAAY... okay.
Alright.
I don't know where the cupcake..
Where the fuck did the cupcake go?
Oh, come back here...
No, NO,
NO!!
Oh oh!
You git- gIT- GIT-- AGGH
Woah-fuck.
Oh-kay..
Is there something hiding under the pizza?
What if I don't? What happens if I don't?
How bout what if I don't--
I don't know if I wanna. I'm not hungry.
I don't know if I like pizza.. oh are your eyes-- oh yeah.
I well I-
Don't tell me to eat it. That's just rude.
Number one.
Number two,
I.. oh...
I- I don't.. wanna...
[Screaming]
AH! FUCK! GOD!
Fuck.. ahh oh...
Really..
Re- eat it. Oh fuck you.
You know what? FUCK you!
[Freddy laughter]
Oh, you li-- what the fuck?
Waiwaiwaiwait what?
What the fuck? Wait a minute...
what the fuck...
What's wrong with the cables? And why are there three?
There's one by the tv...
What the fuck is that about?
Whoa.
You wanna run that by me again?
what the fu-
[screaming]
AHH! FUCKING--
WHAT THE F--
WELL FUCK OFF!
YOU PIECE OF SHIT!
You prick!
HUH?
Fine.
Whatever, God-- screw you! God this stupid cable.
I don't know why this stupid cable is giving me..
Whatever, yeah I know, ah God I know..
I know, I know, I know,
I know, I know, I know, I know, I know.....
Great job.
Well kachow to you and kachow to meee...
Well if you weren't talking over me i would of said
kachow to you and ah kachow to meee..
[kids cheering]
yum yum yum..
If i take two would it be bad?
it would probably be bad if I took two
What if i ate the whole pizza?
[music box]
[kids cheering]
WHOOOOAH
What the hell?
Look at you ya tubby little snot
*baby talk* look at that coochie coochie!
"hehehehe~"
"hEHEHEHEH"
M: OH, wow your voice is more different than i thought i would be.
Puppet: "OOOWHY? WHATS WRONG WITH MY VOICCE? DOESNT IT MATCH MY CUDDLY TUBBLY BODY?"
No, not necessarily as much as i thought it woul-
Puppet: "OOOHH"
"SO MANY THINGS YOU MIGHT MISCONSTRUE ABOUT MY APPEARANCE,"
"BUT LOOKS CAN BE DECEIVING HEHEE~"
OH-kay, alright- w-why do you have to say everything so creepy?
Puppet: "NO REASON AT ALL!"
"I'M JUST TRYIN TO BE CHAARRRMING~"
Okay..I-I don't like where thi-
I got TOO into that..
Thats the problem with that one...
I dunno what came over me...
ALRIGHT! Mr.Parts-
OH, what the fucc?
WHOA- FUCKING WHY?! EVERYTIME!
WHAT THE FUCK???
Ooh! Whoa!
What the fuck...
What the hell ??
What the hell??
What the HELL?!
W H A T  T H E  H E L L ? ! ?
[Loud Noise]
AH- FUH-- FU--
fucking...
y o u    p i e c e   o f   s h i t
Come on!
Good luck with this one, me.
l don't know if I can get my hand that deep in there,
There we go, got it.
Thank you!
Come on come on, get in there!
Okay am I good? Am I good?
*honk*
hEHE!
Holy fuck!
What the hell?
[kids cheering]
WHAT THE HELL??
Oh "Pirate Plunder Bar"
"A treasure trove of taste!"
[cRuNcH]
Delicious!
And nutritious!
I got the lottery on this one!
I don't like being in this world.
I feel like I'm peering too much behind the curtain...
And also, why do those curtains raise??
That one time forever ago?
Okay alright last- last one...
They're not functionally different but everything is so just messed up here!
I think after this what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go and try to find the other tape
OoF
I fucking swear
Uh oh...
Uh oh 0-0 no
Oh, oh oh oH
oH, OH FUCK
! didn't mean to do that!
I DIDN'T MEAN TO DO THAT!!!
AH AHH!
[screaming]
WAAAAH
[static]
Oh...
I thought I was just gonna be doing a playful goof.
[Freddy laughter]
You gonna jumpscare me? *grunting in attack*
What the fuck was that?
Do that again.
[screaming]
AHH- Fuck you!!
Get out, get outta here, get outta here...
Wait what the fuck- oh.
Why are they changing?
Why do they change like that? I don't
like that.
ah-!
AH!!
Oh, oh oh oh oh well I didn't mean that-
Ohhh, well fine. You know what, I'm gonna fuck you up!
Come here ya bitch!
Come on!!
COME ONE!!!
[screaming]
WAAAAAAAH
Fine if that's how you are,
If you're not gonna be polite about it then I'm not gonna be polite about it either!
Get me out of here,
Git- Get me out of here!
Get me out here!!
I've had just about enough with youuuur badass-- Oh
What the fuck?
Did I put it on my head???
OhHhH
Wh-...
Did I put that on my head?
I didn't know I could do that.
[screaming]
[static]
I DIDN'T KNOW I COULD DO THAT
Oh god I can put it on!
No I'm busy with it!
I'm busy.
Hey!
Hey turd nugget!
Hey douche nozzle, hey, loser,
Hey asshole,
Hey stupid fool what are you gonna do about it, huh?
I got the power now! What do you think of this?
I got the... powerrr...
Yeah whatever, you can't get me!
I got your head!
What are you gonna do stuff me in an endoskeleton?
Can't! I'm already stuffed!
What are you gonna do about it, nErD?
Get with the program,
LoSeR
Yeah, suck some of this
D O N G
Okay this,
This is the inner one... definitely ?
Oh shit- There we go! Hoo!
That's a close one!
WOO!
Okay ?
oh- wHOOO
Ta-da!!!
[kids cheering]
I don't think it should be re-opened like this, but
ya know you do you,
you feel what you want to do and I'll...
[kids cheering]
Oh I'll listen alright...
Hey wow!!
Bonnie: "It's mE, BonNiE"
Oh Bonnie...
Ah man you are- you are Wade's apparently nemesis
Bonnie: "Ah wow..."
"I don't know why he thinks that,"
"I kill everybody evenly"
Oh ok, well you know we're all good after I repaired you, right?
B: "Oh yeah--" [choking SFX]
baH fUCKING gOD!!
[labored breathing]
WHY CAN YOU EAT THAT ONE??
WHY CAN YOU EAT
THAT
ONE???
I g- fu-
I swear I'm not trying to, I didn't even
think about that.
I'd completely forgotten that you could
eat them.
Hi.
How are you? Good. Great.
Well that's another one down!
I did all of 'em easy peasy! I'm gonna go back into the real world, ya know, boink!
You're still there? Eeyes you are, you're gettin' a little more visible, I see you !
Okay so what I'm gonna do next,
There's a- there's like some going on here...
There's something going on and it is gonna require me to get those tapes and the coins,
So I'm sure there's gotta be some guide out there that tells exactly where those are,
So my next mission before I
even continue doing any of these ones --
-which I will I'll do these.
It looks like they're not too much terribly di- more  difficult,
I mean th- these are probably the FNAF ones are, but we'll see-
Wait "Night Terrors"? What the fuck? Wait no, what?
Oh shit...
oh no...
In order to get that you got- you probably gotta beat everything.
Yeah okay, alright.
Okay. Um, well we got that to look forward to but I'm gonna look up where those things are
and I'm gonna get those in the next episode
But thank you everybody so much for watching.
Be on the lookout for more fnaf videos coming at you as soon as you can,
subscribe and ring-a-ling that
bell if you want to know exactly when
where and
W H Y
Check out the description for more links to cool videos that I've made in the past,
And thank you everybody for watching!
And as always I will see you
in the next video.
Buh bye!!
Outro song: Shirk - Haunted